trolls fans are you ready for the third
installment trolls banded together will
hit theaters on November 17th and we've
got everything you need to know from the
star studded cast to the brand new
soundtrack and that highly anticipated
NSYNC reunion every trolls movie has a
seriously impressive cast and for the
third installment this already star
studded group is getting even more
exciting rapper kid Cy is Clay got the
drip and sync member and actor Joey
faton is a blaze singer songwriter Troy
saon is Floyd comedian and actor Eric
Andre is John Dory actor and musician
Davi Diggs joins the cast as Spruce oh
sorry a William it's a wild ride where
it has so many different twists and
turns singer songwriter Camila Cabo
joins the cast oh my gosh hello my name
is vaa actor Sosha Mammoth is crimp
comedian and actor Patty Harrison is
Brandy and RuPaul's Drag Race host
RuPaul is Miss Maxine just to name a few
plus Grammy Award winner and Tony Award
nominee Andrew ranold will appear as
veneer and Emmy winning comedian Amy
Schumer will play Velvet the film's two
new villains if you're a fan of the
previous trolls movies you'll be happy
to hear that the original cast is also
back and they're just as happy about it
as we are whenever we get the gang back
together you can just feel how much fun
everybody has Justin Timberlake returns
as Branch okay what are you doing Anna
Kendrick is back as poppy you're so
Christopher Mintz PL is back after
voicing gristle Jr in both the previous
movies tiny diamond first appeared in
trolls World Tour and he's back voiced
once again by SNL star Katan Thompson
this is too much Prince Darnell AKA D
also joined the franchise in the second
movie Zoe Diel is also returning as
Bridget known as as lady glitter
Sparkles I know yavo and Caroline yelt
are back as satin and Chanel that's not
all comedian Ron funes is returning as
Cooper who's also known as Prince Cooper
Kunal nyer is back as guy Diamond after
appearing in the first two movies if
you've heard anything about what's in
store for trolls band together then
you've probably heard that it's making
way for an NSYNC reunion of course
Justin Timberlake former leading man of
the famous early ODS boy band is
returning and this time his former
bandmates Lance Bass JC Chaz Chris Kirk
Patrick and Joey faton are joining him
in September the boy band shocked the
World by hitting the stage at the 2023
MTV Music Video Awards to present an
award to Taylor Swift together now
they've joined forces once again to
record their first song since 2002 this
time for the trolls band together
soundtrack now we all all remember what
a hit Justin Timberlake song Can't Stop
the feeling was when it came out on the
original trolls movies soundtrack now we
can only expect that nsync's new song
better place will have the same effect
when it comes to the trolls Universe the
sky is the limit and things can go quite
a few different ways as director of the
franchise Walt Dawn says the third time
around like how can we push this where
can we go where do we want to go where
should we go and with the trolls it's
almost like there's infinite choices so
it's such a fun playground to be in
while the possibilities for a
Fantastical world like the one in the
trolls movies are endless trolls band
together still has the exciting plot
that we've come to expect from the
franchise so in this third chapter of
the trolls series we learn that Branch
the Justin Timberlake troll he has four
brothers we didn't know about and when
he was a baby they used to all be in a
band together ah yes a boy band so close
to Justin Timberlake's Roots it's all
coming together this this boy band was
called brozone with Branch alongside his
Bros Floyd John Dory Spruce and Clay
after getting together as an official
couple poppy finds out about the secret
boy band of her new boyfriend's past
together branch and Poppy face a rescue
mission when Floyd goes missing at the
hands of brother and sister pop star
villains velvet and veneer it's time we
find the rest of our brothers and get
the band back together aside from the
bright colors and all that wild hair the
trolls franchise is best known for its
standout pop soundtracks and by the
looks of it this may be the best one yet
seeing that musical icons like deid
Diggs Troy Savon and kid cuy have joined
the cast the new soundtrack offers 14
songs and this track list like that of
the previous two films includes both
originals and Classics and seeing as
nsync's original song for the soundtrack
better place already hit number 25 on
the Billboard Hot 100 list yeah it's
safe to say that this soundtrack is
going to be a fan favorite if you can't
wait to see trolls band together it may
be time for a trolls Marathon whether
you're a returning trolls fan or you're
venturing into the franchise for the
first time catching up on the first two
trolls movies is a must before watching
trolls band together and it's clear that
plenty of folks are doing their homework
ahead of the premiere the original
trolls film has made it back to the
Netflix top 10 in preparation for the
third movie and you can also catch the
second installment trolls World Tour on
peacock so be sure to get that trolls
Marathon underway ahead of November 17th
which new cast member are you most
looking forward to hearing in trolls
baned together do you think NSYNC song
will be a success let's discuss it in
the comments and for more videos like
this one be sure to like And subscribe
to the
things